موجز الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله اتهمت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
والرئيسه الروسيه
بعدم الرغبه في التفاوض وقالت ان عليه
العوده الى الواقع وكان بوتين قد قال ان
بلاده مستعده للاتفاق على حلول مقبوله مع
جميع شركاء لتسويه النزاع في اوكرانيا
برفض الجلوس الى طاوله المفاوضات
فقال نائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي دي متر
ميدف ديفين العالم سيستمر على شفا حرب
عالميه ثالثه وكارثه نوويه اذا لم يتم
توفيره ضمانات امنيه لروسيا مسددا على ان
بلاده تبذل قصار جهدها لمنع حدوث ذلك
قالت الخارجيه الصينيه من العلاقات مع
الولايات المتحده تواجه التحديات خطيره
بسبب ما وصفته بعناد واشنطن على رؤيه بجين
منافسا رئيسيا بدوره علينا الجيش الصيني
وتنظيمه تدريبات هجوميه بحريه وجويه حول
جزيره تايوان واعتبرها ردا حازما على ما
وصفه بالتصعيد والاستفزاز الامريكي
التايواني
جاء ذلك بعد اقرار الكونغرس الامريكي
قانون الموازنه العامه الماليه المقبله
الذي يسمح بتقديم مساعده عسكريه فوريه
لتايوان تصلوا قيمتها الى 10 مليارات
الدولار
نقل مراسل الجزيره في افغانستان عن مسؤول
حكومي قوله ان قائد شرطه ولايه بادخان
المولوي عبد الحق وثلاثه من حراسه قتلوا
في تفجير استهدف سيارته الشماليه البلاد
واضاف المصدر ان تفجير وقع امام منزلي
قائد الشرطه فمن في منطقه صيد اباد وهي
عاصمه الولايات في حديث الاخر في بداخان
قال مثلا امنيون الجزيره ان قائد اللواء
العسكريه في الولايه نجا من محاوله اغتيال
قربه
في السودان علنا مجلس السياده عزمه فرض
السلم في ولايه جنوب دارفور بنشر تعزيزات
عسكريه لتامين القرى المتاثره بالاشتباكات
بموجب اتفاق جوبا بدوره لنا والي جنوب
دارفور حاله الطوارئ بالولايه وحضر
التجوال داخل منطقه بليله وكانت مصادر
محليه قد اعلنت مقتل احد عشر شخصا واصابه
نحو 20 في اشتباكات دارت خلال الايام
الماضيه بالولايه كما اعلنا مسؤولون
محليون زوحا 25,000 شخص وطالبوا بفتح
ممرات امنه نحو المخيمات
سجل لا يقيموا جيتياغ شرقيه الصين مليون
اصابه يوميا بفيروس كورونا وسط توقعات
بانتشار الفايروس بوتيره غير مسبوقه في
البلاد واعلنت اللجنه الصحه انها لن تنشر
البيانات اليوميه لاصابات ووفيات كرونه
اعتبارا من امس
اشكركم على متابعه الموجز لما كنتم رابط
اوقاتكم بكل خير